in a tweet from citizens for ethics they
say in this horrifying clip Donald Trump
proposes throwing reporters in jail
where they'll be raped until they give
up their sources his crowd left here we
go you know in this country they leak
all over the place even on the Supreme
Court by the way you have to find the
leaker of the Supreme you have to find
the liquor you know how you find the
liquor they'll say oh this is treasonous
what I said so they can't find the
liquor he leaked all about row v Wade
look this person leaked from the Supreme
Court never happened you know how you
find but they don't want to mention this
because they think it's so terrible you
take the writer
because you're never going to find it
other going through phone records it's
been a long time you take the writer and
or the publisher of the paper a certain
paper that you know and you say who is
the leaker National Security
and they say we're not going to tell you
they say it's okay you're going to jail
and when this person realizes that he is
going to be
the Bride of another prisoner very
shortly